I don't know. I feel like it's really hard to have a bad taxi journey. Oh,
there's someone give you a one-star ones as a customer on Uber.
And I was confused because I don't think I've, haven't done anything in a call,
but maybe I did something that like ruined this man's day and he gave me a
one-stop.
Oh, wow. Yeah. I didn't even know. I had one really.
Memorable, uh, Uber ride in LA. Uh,
and it was again from where we were staying to the convention center,
it was like, yeah, again, another like five, 10 minute ride. And, uh,
and this massive Jeep rocks off, and there's only two of us. I'm like, okay,
that's a bit overkill, but whatever. Okay. Jump in. And it's just this,
like the biggest black dude I've ever seen. Like he's got like, not,
not like fat, like built like pretty. Right. And he's just like,
are you Joey? Right? I'm like, yup. And it's like LA convention center.
All right. I got you like, you know, like super chill.
And so the car drives off like two minutes later and he's like a, oh,
you mind if I put on some music, I'm like, yeah, man, whatever you want.
Yeah. Was like, yeah man, whatever you want. It's all good. And he's like,
all right, cool. He turns on something. Right. And you know,
there's a million different artists.
You can envision a person like that might listen to. Right. It was like,
oh yeah, this is like, you know, it could be any like hardcore hip hop,
whatever. Right. Whatever the dude thinks. So in your comes off
like
a Terry crews moment. You're like white chicks. And I'm just like,
I just started laughing. Like I couldn't help. I'm like, if I laugh,
this man might kill me, but this is just too funny. And I'm like,
you like in your home. And he's like, yeah, it helps me to relax, dude.
That's amazing. That was great. It was so cool. And that's the thing though.
I didn't know if he was like trying to make me laugh or he was actually being
serious, but either way I was like, you know what? I can get into this. Oh,
this is a really cool man. Maybe break. Listen to the menu.
Uber driver. And just troll people with music. Oh yeah. I would as well.
And if I put my favorite music on just lays light.
Watching star opening. No, if I get a new vagina,
if I become a diva driver anime, Oprah use only animate.
I was upset. I said, I was hearing your story. I was like,
have I ever given an Uber driver? A one star? I don't think so.
Because that was my only one. So to me, it's like,
five-star is like encompasses everything from the best experience to my life.
To you got me there in one piece. Yeah. All-star is like,
you literally broke down. You yourself. The cost stinks.
You've killed someone. You, you hit a dog as well. All right.
Four styles that I've just never used a one-star might didn't even know it was
an option. You know, I thought there was.
This is zero stars as well. Right. Then you can give,
what does someone have to do to get zero stars? I mean like the one,
the worst Uber ride that me and AKI went on was in France, in Paris,
Uber and France. Yeah. And this man almost actually got us into a car accident.
The French drivers are not stupid.
I remember he was shouting at everybody in like the,
like the kind of like start, stop kind of driving where I'm just like, bro,
I'm going to be sick all over this color. Yeah.
And he got us there and he was like, okay.
Okay. We're here for, you know, whatever. I was just like, all right, man,
zero stars.
You got scammed in like Italy, right? Uh, yeah, almost.
Like in like.
A lot of, uh, a lot of European countries, uh, except for like, I don't know,
Germany is pretty good for it. I mean a lot of the,
like I think like Prague pretty bad for it and places like that. Yeah.
I like the taxi drivers, mad scam. You and you gotta be like, it sucks.
Cause it's the most and Japanese thing out of it.
You just gotta be like no final pain. That actual.
Fact, like this is ridiculous. Yeah. So.
We landed in, uh, in Rome airport. Um,
and there was just a dude outside of the gate just to be like taxi, taxi.
I know you're tourists. Yeah. Because they know it's for us. Right.
And we were with Archies parents as well. So hockey's dad was like, yeah, yeah,
sure. You know, cause he's an Uber driver and he's like how much to this hotel.
And he looks, and he goes, oh, 50, 50 Euro. And we're like, all right, whatever.
So then he takes us to like the back of the airport where like, it's like right.
Opposite where the hanger is. Right.
And there's just this van and we get into this van and he's like, okay,
hold on. I call my driver and the guy off and we'd left in this van.
And the longer we look around this van, we were like,
we gotta get the out of this van. They're like, this is, this is not a taxi.
Because then I looked up like, you know, standard Italian, like taxi Fest.
To the airport from the hotel.
And we're like a normal, like taxi ride is like 20 years. Yeah.
And just is charging 50. And we're like.
Don't, don't listen to those in Europe, man.
Like that they'll they'll try and get you away.
Cause it's always going to be like an official taxi stand.
So we, so we immediately, like, we didn't even wait for them.
We just like grabbed that. Got out,
went to the regular taxi stand and we're like, all right, thank God.
I mean,
I'm pretty sure for like any country you want to go to the official taxi staff.
Or some countries have way stricter rules on taxis than others. And like,
even if you get one, somebody ran up, you're pretty. Yes.
A lot of countries you'll still get like I'm in Japan. You get,
you get to anyway, you're going to get the standard fare. Right, right. Same in,
uh, Germany and UK as well. I'm pretty sure it was well something, but yeah.
Yeah. We learned our lesson that we were about to get,
I don't know where the this guy was going to take it.
Literally what they warn against as you're a kid.
[inaudible]